I'm Ron Brockman head of Yahoo labs and
the chief scientist for Yahoo
our focus in the labs are on the key
sciences that we use to support a wide
variety of products in Yahoo we use
machine learning technology to help
understand what restoring users like to
read and we've actually deployed that in
the product on Yahoo's homepage and that
gets a billion clicks a month one of the
great emphases at Yahoo now is in mobile
technology you'll probably familiar with
the Yahoo mobile weather app in order to
find photos from our Flickr database we
need an underlying strong computational
thinking figure out how out of a vast
array of literally millions of
photographs to find the ones that just
match for the right time in the right
place this is all part of the general
theme that Yahoo Labs has around what we
call personalization there could be new
stories or very important to our
advertisers that could be matching a
high quality delightful ad to a user who
just needs to see that at the right time
in the right place we help our product
units create exciting products but we
don't flash Yahoo labs in the front and
do things that are kind of flashes in
the pan we do personalization at
internet scale to a billion users